[Music]
we've wrapped and Hannah is back but in
different Hannah you'll see very
different to season one here is
everything we know about 13 reasons why
season 2 it kicks off a few months after
season 1 I feel like there's a lot of
new story they're going to learn and a
lot from the past like in a familiar
timeline that we already know whether
that involves clay and Hannah I'm not
sure this season particularly is a lot
about recovery looking at Jessica
looking at the people who are affected
and just going from where we left off in
season 1 and and not finishing their
season 2 is all original content we're
starting from scratch and you can see
some of the other characters developed
that we're not so so developed in season
1 or in the book you know you can see
more of an ensemble the showrunner where
would you like to see the story go you
know Hannah made 13 tapes and told us 13
very specific stories but there's a lot
she didn't tell us and I want to know
more about that I want to know what her
secrets are I'm about to tell you the
story of my life more specifically why
my life ended it's naturally going to
progressively get to more of an
emotional place and due to the nature of
the story we're telling so I'm sure
we're all heading in some dark
directions again how do you feel like
the reaction of the conversation that
came from season one affected how you
guys went into season two that's that's
a really good question I mean I
definitely like personally I was
conscious of it but I think at the end
of the day everyone on the show is very
committed to telling the story and the
most thought that most authentic way
possible the show is taking action
following the reaction to season one in
other ways to in hopes of helping
parents discuss heavy topics with teams
an online viewing guide will be provided
a plus each episode will feature a
custom intro if you ever feel you need
someone to talk with reach out to a
parent a friend a school counselor or an
adult you trust call a local helpline or
go to 13 reasons why dot info I care so
much about this project my mom and I
believe in the message we hope that
people enjoy it
and Selena Gomez who executive produces
a series with her mom Mandy TV is even
more hands-on in season two she's always
checking in she's always making
important decisions given important not
so she's boss I love her what kind of
conversations do you hope are generated
from this series I think I think that
for me I'm really big on vulnerability I
think people are really scared to be
honest with themselves I want people to
know that every every single life is
valuable that their voice can be heard
and that there are people who are
willing to be there for them perhaps the
craziest change secrecy and security how
crazy is the confidentiality with these
scrimp spent but the effects are really
you know front of you this season feels
like a very different show not just
because the content but also just
because of you know the approaches and
precautions that we've had to take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]